realiza una tabla y resuelve y dice así
un biólogo realiza una investigación
sobre el impacto de tres diferentes
bebidas azucaradas a base de agua para
la habilidad de las abejas de producir
miel el toma dos litros de la bebida am
la cual contiene 40 por ciento de azúcar
y como estoy viendo que vamos a utilizar
muchos datos déjame ir creando la tabla
entonces en mi primera columna voy a
poner la cantidad de bebida en mi
segunda columna el porcentaje de azúcar
que tiene esta bebida y por último y
esto creo que va a ser muy importante
voy a poner aquí la cantidad azúcar no
la cantidad de azúcar la cantidad de
azúcar que vamos a obtener de cada una
de estas bebidas y fíjate bien empezamos
con 2 litros de la bebida a la cual
contiene 40 por ciento de azúcar
entonces vamos a escribirlo de una vez
la bebida la bebida
de la bebida vamos a tomar 2
litros 2 litros y de estos 2 litros de
la bebida el 40 por ciento es azúcar el
40 por ciento de estos dos litros es
azúcar y entonces si yo lo que quiero
saber es la cantidad de azúcar que hay
en estos dos litros
hay que multiplicar dos litros por con
este por por el 40% es decir por el 0.4
lo cual me da 0.8 0.8 litros son de
azúcar muy bien esto en la bebida a 0.8
litros son de azúcar mientras que 1.2
litros son de agua es por eso que
tenemos una bebida azucarada al 40 por
ciento ahora a esto le vamos a agregar
1.2 litros de la bebida de entonces la
bebida bien son 1.2 litros 1.2 litros y
bueno no nos dice qué porcentaje tenemos
de azúcar pero nos dice que vamos a
obtener una nueva solución llamada
bebidas y entonces aquí vamos a ponerle
la suma de estas dos nos va a dar la
bebida sé de la cual date cuenta que
vamos a obtener 3.2 litros es decir la
suma de la vez
a la bebida y esta bebida se entiende un
25 por ciento de azúcar entonces el
porcentaje de azúcar que tenemos es un
25 por ciento y pues también podemos
obtener de aquí cuál es la cantidad de
azúcar que tenemos de estos 3 puntos 2
litros porque es 3.2 por el 25 por
ciento es decir 3.2 por punto 25 lo cual
es 0.8 litros es muy fácil lo único que
estoy haciendo es tomándome un cuarto de
3.2 litros es decir el 25 por ciento y
nos preguntan cuál es el porcentaje de
azúcar en la bebida avn así que vamos a
llamar a este porcentaje de azúcar x el
porcentaje de azúcar de la bebida pm es
equis y vamos a pensar que ya está en
decimal para no meternos en más
problemas por lo tanto si nosotros
queremos saber la cantidad de azúcar que
tiene la bebida bien pues habría que
multiplicar 1.2 por x porque x ya lo
estamos viendo en su forma decimal 1.2 x
es la cantidad de azúcar que tenemos en
la bebida
ahora date cuenta de lo siguiente la
suma de la cantidad de azúcar de la
bebida a más la suma de la cantidad de
azúcar de la bebida bem tiene que ser
igual a la cantidad de azúcar que tiene
la bebida ce pero como la cantidad de
azúcar de la bebida am y de la bebida ce
es la misma esto significa que x es
igual a cero y eso nos da pie a la
siguiente ecuación 0.8 litros mas 1.2 x
litros es igual a 0.8 litros de azúcar
pero si yo restó de aquí 0.8 de ambos
lados me queda que 1.2 x es igual a 0 o
que x es igual a 0 es decir para obtener
la bebida sé que tenga 0.8 litros de
azúcar tenemos que agregarle a la bebida
a una bebida vez que sea agua pura wow
esto está genial es decir que no
contenga azúcar que tenga el 0% de
azúcar